[Música]
hoy vamos directo a Ciudad de México
porque como lo mencionamos antes en el
noticiero este jueves el presidente
ucraniano habló por primera vez ante la
cámara mexicana de diputados si bien
esta clase de intervenciones las ha
hecho antes en Europa y en Estados
Unidos para promover el apoyo a Ucrania
a bolodin Mercedes que se le ha visto
poco en América Latina y decidió hacerlo
en un país que no ha respaldado
abiertamente
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal
Mario carbonell en la capital mexicana
Mario buenas noches para usted y
cuéntenos quién le pidió específicamente
selensky a los mexicanos y que
coincidencias marcó entre los dos
pueblos
Hola qué tal Así es en su discurso el
presidente
pues destacó que México los pueblos de
México y de Ucrania coinciden en
defender la vida de personas inocentes
ante los ataques dijo que pues es por
ello que hace un llamado a México a que
defina qué parte de la fórmula para la
paz que ha propuesto Ucrania va a apoyar
y así definir su liderazgo en el mundo
se refería a selensky a la fórmula que
se basa en el precisamente la defensa de
la vida luchar por una solución
diplomática y también por el respeto a
la soberanía y el diálogo con los países
del mundo
en ese sentido zelensky llamó a México
también a mirar al mundo a través de los
ojos de una mujer una mujer y una madre
de familia que ha sido víctima de los
misiles de Rusia que han destruido
tu casa que han acabado con la vida de
su hijo es este ejemplo el que puso el
presidente ucraniano para tratar de
mover un poco las conciencias en México
y lograr el apoyo concretamente en esta
propuesta que ha hecho de que América
Latina organice una Cumbre una Cumbre
regional para unir esfuerzos unir voces
en apoyo precisamente a Ucrania y contra
la invasión rusa y dijo que en este
sentido México sería de gran ayuda para
lograr que se concrete esta Cumbre
latinoamericana en favor de la paz y
cuéntenos qué respondieron los diputados
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que existe
una división política ya que el gobierno
de Andrés Manuel López Obrador no ha
apoyado abiertamente a Ucrania
Así es bueno en principio los diputados
sobre todo los de movimientos ciudadano
que son los que organizaron este grupo
de amistad México Ucrania expresaron su
completa solidaridad con ese país
dijeron que no por ejemplo Salomón
chertorisky que es uno de ellos
reprochó la equivalencia moral dijo de
poner en el mismo estatus al agresor y
al agredido dijo que esto ha
representado Pues el fracaso moral más
grande de la diplomacia mexicana y de la
diplomacia latinoamericana
no obstante bueno el presidente de los
diputados no de los diputados sino de la
junta de coordinación política el
morenista Ignacio miel dijo que esa
postura no es la del Congreso mexicano
que es únicamente la de los diputados de
ese grupo de amistad concretamente los
del partido opositor movimiento
ciudadano esto Pues motivó que la
embajada de Rusia en México agradeciera
a la junta de coordinación de diputados
por esta postura equilibrada ante Pues
esta posición de México que como ya lo
comentabas no ha sido completamente de
condena a la invasión